ronald you do have uh sharing rights
right now um and i wanted to let
everyone know we're going to be starting
in just a moment i do have to
start the live streaming for our
linkedin
live audience so
it's a process
takes about 45 seconds
apologize for that but
so far they haven't figured out how to
just do it push of a button
and
one more step
all right and welcome to our linkedin
live audience our youtube audience and
of course everyone here
live with us
in our webex session i'm stuart creek
i'm a marketing manager here at simply
learn
and i'm here today with ronald van loon
who is the ceo of intelligent world
and a leading expert in data science
artificial intelligence machine learning
he's going to talk to us today about
data skills for non-data scientists and
why data is important to everybody in
their everyday work today so
with that um let me start by pointing
out the controls for
the webex session for those of you on it
the
the questions for ronald should go into
the q a box which is the lower left of
your
webex tool
and
those will get queued up i'll ask those
of ronald at the q a portion of the
webinar toward the end
can put information in the chat we'll
see that
but we'll be paying most attention to
the q a for
questions
so
with that i'd like to introduce
uh well let's start with a poll actually
we have a couple questions uh one at the
beginning one in the end
and this is our beginning poll
so i'm going to ask you
my
system cooperates
what is
your current job role
and if you're watching on live stream
you can put a answer into the
comments
and we'll give you about another 20
seconds or so
the second part of the question is
we've been asking during the pandemic
because we want to make sure that people
are holding up to all the changes with
lockdowns and surges and
vaccines and what have you it's a
confusing world we live in
sort of just doing a little bit of a
check-in with you
and we'll
close the poll and i will show you the
result so
the
largest chunk of our audience uh almost
40 percent ronald are students today
um we have a smattering of other people
with
fewer data scientists and data engineers
than we would normally have for one of
your webinars because of the topic i
think um and
almost everybody is checking in is doing
at least okay
if not better so
um it's good to hear from our audience
and
let me start by introducing you um
so
ronald
is the ceo of intelligent world as i
mentioned um
he is one of the foremost thought
leaders in data science and in digital
transformation
data being so important in the world
today
his
thoughts and insights are in
very high demand um he's
well recognized worldwide as
an influencer and an expert in the in
the area and has uh
authored a number of uh
blog posts online essays
um
he's a
very busy speaker and we're very
fortunate to have him here today so
welcome ronald
thank you thank you stuart
for the kind introduction let's see if
the slides work yeah they work now
so welcome everybody and thanks for for
joining us today for for this discussion
so we're going to discuss today
data science for people who aren't data
scientists and we saw that we have a lot
of students and other type of roles a
little bit less data scientist which was
expected
but that's what we're going to discuss
and maybe you're wanting to become a
data scientist in the future or you want
to know where to start or maybe you are
looking to expand your existing career
by learning data science skill sets that
can help you
there could be all different kind of
backgrounds and i i'm sure everybody has
its own background and its own journey
but the point of today's discussion is
to help you understand that the use of
data science skills are expanding what
we see is that all businesses are
realizing the potential and
the value of data and this is impacting
how people do their jobs across all
different kinds of industry and there's
i think hardly any exception in in the
industry
and by learning and by exploring various
fields of study in data science you can
better prepare your career for success
whether you are a data scientist or
whether you are not and have a different
type of role within an organization and
because the skills that you can learn in
data science they are highly
differentiated and they're highly
customizable
so you can take this as an opportunity
to learn these type of important skills
that can bring you value to different
businesses to to your career to
different organizations to different
industries but also it's it's clear that
organizations across these industries
are in the need of data scientists and
people who understand the impact of data
and technology on the business
so even
if you aren't a data scientist which is
i think 98 percent
learning data science skills are very
important so because businesses are
using data for strategic design for
innovation for optimization for decision
making basically for for everything
and if you can demonstrate an
understanding of data and you can learn
how data is impacting the workforce
you will be in a position to augment
your existing skills you
deliver more value to your employers to
your customers to yourself and
ultimately set
yourself up for for more future success
but i don't think that's all
learning data science skills can be a
lifelong educational pursuit due to the
relevance of data science and it impacts
on the future
so you can really set yourself apart
from the competition in your career and
evolve and grow alongside data science
development
over time and it's not something that
you can start and say hey in three
months you're ready
this domain is developing so incredibly
quickly that you need to keep up to date
um
every year
maybe even every month
keep studying and keep improving
yourself and
what i'm about to say might be the most
important thing that we're going to
discuss today you'll eventually start to
change the way
that you think about the world the work
the society and business because you
start thinking about our data you begin
to recognize the connection between
complex systems in the world around you
and discover how they relate to to each
other and and this has to do with the
cult this system thinking so looking at
the different situation and variables
looking at
looking for consequences and solutions
to problems and experiences
and this combines your analytical
mindset with your own curiosity
and your own
creativity
and the bottom line is
apply these skills that you learn in in
data science to enhance your everyday
work across the industry
and this this will help you to discover
and to explore the value of data science
and and how it's
many fields and many applications can be
applied to modify and to improve um the
efficiency in your work
and also most of the time even the fun
in your work so the impact of data
are really far-reaching and every
industry is impacted by data today and
this makes data science skills more
relevant than ever before
so it doesn't matter
what industry you're working in it could
be agriculture or maybe you're in
manufacturing or in retail or in
healthcare or or in finance or different
service business
it doesn't matter what your job role is
either
you could be in sales you could be
marketing logistics management hr or it
it doesn't matter so learning to use
data science skills in your everyday
work will will elevate your career and
will elevate your mind and help you
think about your work and and your life
in a new and in a different way
and also i think there are so many
data science fields that branch off or
intersect with many popular sectors you
can think about cyber security
automation
so
there are many different sectors so you
can potentially
explore new career opportunities in high
growth sectors if you're now not in a
high growth sector and if you want to
change your career and and lastly
as data science evolves
so will the tools and the technologies
that are used to work in
to give an example this means
that more user-friendly tools and more
capabilities will be available to
explore the use of data
you have no code solutions already
you have auto ml
where the
models are developed by
by the ai or using new applications on
your phone or on your tablet that can
enhance your work which are data driven
um supported by by ai which makes it a
lot easier to be a modern type of data
scientist without knowing every aspect
of of a data scientist
all right so let's get into the
discussion today let's see
what kind of questions we have so we
have prepared a couple of questions and
tell you more about
how you can learn to use data science in
your different everyday work
even if you're you're not a data
scientist so the first topic we would
like to dive into is why it is so
important to learn data skills for your
work
even if you don't are this data
scientists
and i first would like to to put things
a little bit into perspective
if you look to mckinsey which is a
leading consultancy firm
they forecast that by 2025 smart
workflows and integrated and seamless
human to machine interactions will be
commonplace
most employees will use data to optimize
almost all aspects of their work
i repeat most of the employees will use
data to optimize almost all aspects of
their work so if you think about your
own work what you're doing during the
day
all these aspects will be impacted by
data will be impacted by ai either to
augment you some parts will be replaced
and you need to redevelop your your
skills
and if you look to 2025 it's just around
the corner so in just a few short years
everyone's work will be impacted by data
and i think it is already today but it
will be impacted much much more so
people will be responsible for utilizing
data as an integral part of their
everyday
work and everyday life
so this is a perfect example of why you
need to learn data skills at your work
even if you aren't a data scientist
so the more you can learn about data and
improve your own data education
the better you will be prepared for your
data driven future workplace
and i think
everybody's thinking about this career
especially in this uncertain times so
being prepared
to to have the best position for your
career i think is crucial
and this is i think yeah it's it's so
amazingly um interesting and as you can
imagine i'm a little bit biased because
i i love to work with with data
but because people in the workforce will
will be training and will be using data
science skills
it doesn't matter what job role you have
and whether you are working at the
company from one person a freelancer a
thousand people or ten thousand people
it really doesn't matter so the reason
for that is because of today enterprises
what you see they are evolving they are
becoming data driven across every corner
of the enterprise and it can be a large
enterprise but you can also have small
organ
organizations and they
embedding data into their operations
into the processes into any decision
making that they do and especially now
using it for for
augmenting
the workforce and parts will be replaced
replace certain tasks as well especially
repetitive redundant tasks
so organizations they are exploring
artificial intelligence and they are
exploring automation and expanding their
their infrastructures to incorporate
digital designs and accommodating data
centers whether on-premise or whether
it's in in the cloud
and these data architectures they are
growing as organizations they're
modernizing
they put a lot of money into this
and there's a transformation taking
place
on the digital level as what we see is
that it environments are changing to
further enable traditional use cases
while adding flexibility to incorporate
all kind of new and all kind of
different type of use cases and much
faster than ever before and especially
cloud is driving this
substantially
and as a result that we see is
organization are enabling advanced
analytics capabilities and this requires
real-time data so organizations are
creating new data architectures that not
only enable and connect new capabilities
but also provides scalability enterprise
scalability
so there is this business evolution
taking place on the technology level to
incorporate the use of data and this is
going on already for for 25 years but
the the use of
clouds and the more compute power
really accelerating this substantially
right now
but there's also
a cultural evolution taking place across
the enterprise as people in the business
gradually learn
to value and learn the value of the data
how it impacts the business how it
impacts their own daily
life their daily operation the daily
work
and
this makes them realize
this is important so data is going to
essentially give people
more freedom
it gives you the opportunity to
collaborate it gives you the opportunity
to innovate to be more creative and
create work environments that foster
this continuous growth and improvement
if you take benefit of this
and this will help organizations to
develop
exceptional employee and exceptional
customer experience i believe which will
lead to more amazing products more
amazing services more amazing
applications at the faster pace than
what we have ever seen seen before
and if this this is what's going to be
expected in any work environment
and this is let's say forecast for 2025
and it's going on right now already but
it will be everywhere in every aspect so
imagine
what your career is going to look like
in in the coming years
and by then there will be many available
databases that are flexible that are
organized giving teams the capabilities
to better understand data relationships
and this will turn
accelerate this will accelerate
ai innovation and more applications
that's going to augment
consumers enterprises and you as a
workforce as well and
what we see is that the workforce is
evolving very fast and because of data
is so important and relevant for
business success and its longevity
so the current state of data and
organizations today will look a lot
different in the near future
and as i mentioned cloud is an important
driver for this and currently
organizations are connecting their
disparate data
and systems across various environments
online
offline on-premise
in the cloud
and they're learning how to enhance data
management by providing seamless data
access at a single or multiple locations
but in the near future these data assets
will be much more organized
better available so that organizations
and people will have much easier time
using it to to meet the customer needs
and overcome different business
challenges with the help of data with
the help of analytics with the help of
ai and the way data assets are
integrated
will continuously evolve
will evolve faster and faster every
month to the point where organizations
can repeatedly use them in a very cost
effective effective way
and ultimately
i think it's important to learn data
science skills at your work even if
you're not a data scientist and that's
what we're discussing today of course
because data is vital
to your business transformation
to your success to the continuity of
your career and of your business
and everyone will
need at the very least a basic
understanding of how data impacts
an organization
the industry
your role your career
and also the realization that you will
be required to use data to enhance and
to improve and to augment your own work
in some capacity so stuart i think
and i hope it's clear
this is why
these data science skills are are so
incredibly important to have them and to
spend
tons of time on it if you have it or you
need to make it i think and it will
really help you to boost your your
career
yeah i mean my wife is a registered
nurse and she's been a nurse long enough
to go from the the period of
uh
recording patient information on paper
and into a physical paper chart to now
everything is done digitally
but the the difference
is not just that
you record the information in the
digital format but now that information
can be fed back
to the care team the nurses the doctors
pharmacists um in a real-time basis so
you know you can now get a call from
your pharmacist
when they see that your
blood sugar monitor
for
diabetes has
recorded an
unusual value and
all of this is happening in in real time
and it's all driven by
data coming from so many different
sources so
um
that leads to the next question
what are the important data skills
that people should learn
to apply into their everyday work in
these different domains and and what
makes those important
yeah i think a great question i really
liked your example about healthcare
what you showed is the importance of
data and how data can be used i was
talking this morning to quite an
innovative company where they could
detect by a voice whether you have
covert or not with an 85
accuracy so even further if you think
what is possible with data if you can
hear my voice voice you can detect if i
have covit or a copd or a
mental
mental disturbance
which is amazing
so you can see data everywhere
your voices data
and your voice gives you information
about even your health conditions from
from data points that they can detect so
it's incredibly
where
and where there is data and how you can
use it
your whole face your whole digital
identity is data everything is is data
and gives you amazing opportunities and
then coming back to your questions what
are the important data skills that you
need to get and make these type of
these type of applications and one and
understand them but also make make them
work
so first i think
if you look to the skills this can vary
depending on your job and on your
business of course we're talking about
many different industries many different
job roles
and they all use data in it in a
different way
but
for this particular discussion i think
we're going to stick to to generalized
data skills that can really kick start
your your existing career
or help you find your way as a new data
scientist looking to start or to expand
your education
so i'd like to start a part of the
discussion by talking about an important
skill which you probably not expect but
that's the importance of communication
so
you can have all the data in the world
and and your business can
be completely future ready but if you
can't communicate your data findings or
explain it in a way that's meaningful
or that makes sense to yourself or to
different people within your
organization
then you can't maximize the value of
your data to your organization and it
doesn't matter
what your job role is
whether it's as a data scientist or even
you are a data a data scientist at all
effective communication is essential to
all data scientists and people who want
to derive value from the data and i mean
about
explaining what the data is telling you
in simple clear language
which will be i think the large majority
of people in the workforce will need
this
this skill
and communication and then collaboration
go really hand in hand you'll be
talking to and you're working with
people across different departments with
varying drop roles and your experience
levels when it comes yeah different
experience levels
when it comes to data analytics
different
different let's say thoughts about data
and being a great communicator means
that you have to listen
learn to understand the perspectives and
the workflows of others
and embrace the level of flexibility so
that you can adjust your work to
incorporate different views and then
describe data findings in a way that's
relatable to each unique person and and
the way they think and the way that they
operate in their job
so being
agile at your job
is quite important as as business
continuously navigate and explore all
kinds of new ideas and all kinds of new
solutions that they implement and they
do this faster and faster because the
capabilities are there and the
developments become easier
so learning data science skills helps
you
more seamlessly fit into an organization
plan
into their strategy as they need to
reshape their workforce as well and and
their future trajectory so they are more
equipped for this
data-driven future
and
this data-driven future with with remote
work right now
which
brings me basically to my next data
skill that people should learn in their
everyday work which is having
business understanding
and business knowledge
it's maybe also not the first thing that
you
expect to hear but it's very important
it's really
important to learn about the impacts of
technology the impacts of data the
impacts of analytics of ai
on your business and we were just
discussing this this healthcare example
where it's
beyond imagination
that your voice can analyze with an app
whether you have a certain disease at
least i think if we were discussing this
a couple of years ago we we could not
even imagine it and now it's already
there
so
it is really important to learn about
the impact of technology on your
business and then you can think about
technologies like like data like cloud
like ai to to transform the organization
to prepare for the digital future and
you can be part of this and this entails
learning about your business challenges
this entails educating yourself about
popular digital transformation
technology use cases
this entails making industry specific
connections to to data and to technology
and the combination and learning how
organizations are are shaping the
employee and the customer experience
by using data
so
i think it's important to remember the
global big data analytics market will
grow with the compound annual growth
rate by 30 percent which is
immense
and this is in the coming years till
2025
and businesses are making substantial
investments in data and ongoing
technology transformation so
your data science education should be
ongoing as well especially
in your understandings of business at
cumin so that you can evolve in your
career alongside with the exponential
growth of of data and the exponential
growth of new possibilities of data new
possibilities
due to the tremendous increase of
compute power it gives tremendous
possibilities and capabilities
what you can can can do with data so the
combination of
data science communication and business
knowledge will act as the foundation for
exploring new careers trajectories
nuclear knowledge
and this will act as a foundation for
exploring
your new type of
opportunity
a new type of workplace
and this will teach you not to be afraid
to ask questions and engage your your
work community in an effort to utilize
data at this at most
stuart this is a short overview of the
main skills that people should work on
and i think everybody can work on quite
easily
from today onwards
yeah and
i'd add an example that
one of the things about data is
to be able to understand what it's
actually telling you
so
the data skills that around you know
what
information can you actually pull out of
data that you're being given if you're
shown a
chart of information or if you're shown
a
a
visualization
are you you know what is the real
information that you're being told and
the and the flip side of that is if you
have data collected in your in your job
things are
and you you may not be in a job where
you think you're collecting data but you
are for example a machinist in the
factory
who's collecting uh information
about the
tolerances and quality of each piece
that that
he or she makes
um is generating data that needs to be
presented in a certain way for people to
make intelligent decisions about whether
that machine's working well
and so
it's important for for people in those
roles to understand
what is the data they're generating what
can it tell people
and
what
ways are there to present that so that
it tells the right story
and you also don't want to be misled by
somebody using data who's trying to tell
you the wrong story with it so
there's a lot of interesting aspects in
that
respect when we're talking about
learning the skills that you discussed
what are
some of the
paths or
avenues that people can follow
to learn those skills
yeah again
i think a good good follow-up question
to to dive in
i think we we have some good news here
that we have a lot of opportunity to
explore various areas of data science
and to expand and to customize
your specific educational path so it's
your own journey and everybody has its
own journey
and i think if we look back 10 years 15
years ago there wasn't
a lot of resources available to expand
your education in data science
but thanks to
the high demand on one hand
for for data scientists and the
necessity to use data analytics for
business innovation and growth
today even popular universities or
basically almost every university
are starting to offer courses and
education designed for data scientists
data
and data science is in every aspect also
in in the educational
in the educational industry
and which brings me basically to my
first point of the question is
there are tailored courses and
certificates available to you that you
can learn about data science
at any experience level if you have no
experience if you are a
very experienced data scientist you can
completely customize your educational
path and design your own curriculum
based upon your interest and
on your existing career and your your
future career
and of course companies like simply
learn offer lots of different online
certifications even those designed from
prestigious universities like the purdue
university
which is a top technology university in
in in california so many companies like
this that offer
online certifications in data science
where the first
the first one is is to have data science
resources and education available
to you as a student
so
there's a lot of experience in in
tailored
education as well i think and um you can
partner with other institutions and
universities to expand
um all the different type of of courses
and mix it to get your own
ideal journey
and certifications help you prepare for
specialized education that you can't
normally find
in in a traditional learning environment
or in a traditional school and when you
complete your certification it's a proof
to the existing and to the prospective
employers that you have that experience
and that's very important because
everybody can
explain and tell what they they have
done but if you have a certification
certificate for this helps you really in
in moving forward and just show it and
you get the stamp of approval
all right let's let's take some time to
talk about another way to learn specific
data science skills which is through
mental that program for example
so choosing a mentor can be an important
step in your career
so be sure if you choose a mentor that
reflects your own interests that has a
good personal click
that he has the he or she has the
experience working in the industries
that you prefer
maybe even in the region but i think the
region is less important nowadays
or that they have experience with
companies that that you are interested
in
and
in as well in the career and the
position that you could see yourself so
a mentor that
is in a position that you would like to
to achieve
i think that can help you a lot because
seeing
and and working with such a person makes
it very clear what what you can can do
yourself as well and mentors generally
have a lot of unique business
connections built over the the years of
networking so they can help you build
and grow your own connections and your
own network with other professionals on
platforms um on all different kinds of
platforms and whether it's the social
platforms where you can easily connect
with each other whether it's at
hackathons or other social gatherings
there's many different different ways
but
leverage
the network from your mentor
the mentors also have a lot of hands-on
experience and they're able to
to give you interesting insider tips
often help you to push
past your career uncertainty and narrow
it
in on your skills on your strengths on
your weaknesses
but be aware
if you have a mentor who's not up to
date anymore
then it's going to be hard he needs to
stay up to date from all the latest
developments to to keep you coaching in
in the right direction in the right way
so mentors have been
through
many challenges through experiences
working with organizations they um they
are professionals across industries and
they can pass the knowledge down to you
and and
instead of let's say doing it by trial
and error yourself which takes
a long long long time
so working with mentors can be an
ongoing experience that
i think can last a lifetime never stop
learning and maybe you can
change the mentor at a certain moment if
you outpaced him or you want to go in a
different direction but i think
learning from other people um is very
helpful and it's much faster than trying
it out yourself and and you can turn
them
to for for guidance basically at any
stage of your professional career
and lastly
i think it's important to join the
different data science communities to to
enhance your your reading your learning
whether it's online whether it's
all kinds of
communities where you discuss certain
problems whether it's hackathons
join these communities see if you can
learn from from the other ones if it
doesn't work go to the next one
until you find the right fit where you
think hey this group can will really
help me moving forward and
participate especially on social
with these communities and and try to
contribute to them as well and give you
value and then you get definitely your
value back so communities are a great
resource for for finding current and
up-to-date news information about data
science
you can actively engage in interesting
live discussions
in workshops and hackathons a lot of
things are available for free online
as well simplylearn has a lot of
resources available on
on youtube for example
you can ask all different kinds of
questions that you have you can meet new
peers that have similar type of interest
and and career pursuits like yourself
and team up with with these people and
learn from these other people so
communities often have
also a fun and entertaining feel for you
for them as long as you contribute to to
the community as well so this can feel a
lot lighter and more fresh and and
break up your education into more
consumable
and maybe even a more friendly type of
format so combining
online education but combine it with
some some practical either hackathons or
community discussions and workshop as
well
so communities are also often very
diverse so you will be able to narrow in
on exactly what type of experience is
best for you
and you can join them yeah of course as
many as you want as online there are so
many different different communities
available so
stuart i think if we look for example to
uh
to simply learn online boot camps are a
great way to to scale up and
to manage your job transformation
as well nowadays so
many possibilities to
to scale up
and and
you you've got opportunities to
pick up
particular individual skills like
understanding
quality control through lean six sigma
or you can look at
picking up uh
complete suites of skills that are
oriented towards a job role so
there's lots of different options there
i think
we'll move on the next question i think
we had lined up was the
question about how
thinking like a data scientist
can enhance your career what are the
things that
understanding data
does
that give you a leg up over other people
in your in your
same job role
yeah i think we discussed it already in
the beginning um how expanding your data
science education can help your career
trajectory and also
the thinking like a data scientist can
help you um so let me get into a little
bit more specifics
so thinking like a data scientist will
help you solve business problems um is
your challenge marketing or sales
related is it more customer facing do
you have an i.t or
maybe a system challenge or is it more a
leadership challenge for for hr
if you start thinking
how you can solve the problem with the
help of data which data you need which
data points you need and whether it's
real time whether it's on demand
where you need to combine it with which
data how you need to visualize the data
whether you need to develop models on
top of it
that you need to run to get the answers
this is a different way of thinking
about
how to solve the problems so there are
countless
challenges that can be addressed by
using data
every industry every business every role
you can solve
many problems with the help of data and
approaching your work every day with
this type of mindset
and and the knowledge to use data to
overcome those problems
will set you ahead of your
i call it competition let's say your
your colleagues and make you stand out
amongst all your peers and boost your
boost your career
so this type of approach can aid you in
being reactive in overcoming challenges
but also develop skills so you are even
proactive
using more a predictive analytics skill
set thinking ahead what can happen come
with proposals already proposals already
how to
help an organization in the direction of
their vision and think about the next
step what they can achieve already
with with the help of of data so
constantly searching for new solutions
to unanswered questions even if you can
trigger an questions which are in line
with the vision of an organization
you become proactive you will be seen as
an expert
and you will be
start guiding your organization in in
the right direction
and you constantly have to try to
leverage existing data and knowledge to
explore and solve
to something that you maybe don't know
yet
that's extremely valuable to any
organization and
that's where
innovation is born
and you have to approach data science
with a level of curiosity curiosity to
to solve the unknown
and try to measure the outcomes to the
variables for example if you make a
change to x how will it impact why or
why is this outcome happening so data
science can can really help you to
discover the answers to
the most pressing business
questions there are or questions that
even are not
questioned by the other people in in the
industry
and data science also helps you to
understand the connection between
the systems and the business so where is
your data located
how can you access it what types of data
visualization tools are you using or
how does data move between systems or
how is data changing the way you work or
how can you use data to enhance your
workflow and you might be thinking
why why should i know this
if you don't know this then
you do not detect the flaws within your
data because data has a lot of flaws
it's it's hardly ever complete
it's hardly 100 correct
so you need to be able to understand
what's underneath it to understand the
problems
and to detect these type type of
problems
and this sounds quite rudimentary i
think or or
you don't understand how it's going to
help you but you have to realize that
organizations are spending
millions and millions
of dollars or euros in developing their
infrastructure to support the use of
data so they spend countless time and
energy
connecting the systems integrating data
across the systems and it goes a long
way if you're working
with a company if you can make the
connection between the data between the
business and between the systems and
this is especially important if if
you're a data scientist or if you want
to become one or if you want to think
like a data scientist then so even if
you are a beginner or
or
if you know
how data helps your business operation
and why it is connecting different
systems throughout the the business this
will help you train you will help you
train to think
about data and understand the data
better so i think the point is
learning to think like a data scientist
trains you to become a better become
better at problem solving better at
teaching you
how to look for and how to find
solutions to to challenges and achieving
your goals in in your work
so basically what
what i'm saying is that data science
skills will train you to be
reactive to be adaptable
even
in the face of strong adversity
and if you you hone your skills over
time and develop predictive analytic
skills and thinking
you will be
more proactive at finding solutions to
the most pressing challenges maybe even
challenges that don't exist yet you it
gives you the capability to look further
ahead
and come with amazing innovations based
upon on data so think about
about your job right now or
the job that you want to have or
what would you be able to accomplish if
you could predict outcomes and if you
can be more proactive at your job today
or how much more value would that bring
to your job how much time would would
that save if you come up with solutions
that improve your work on a daily basis
and how much money would that bring to
you maybe extra salary raise or how much
money would it bring to your company if
you bring value to your company
they will value that and and you will
get a better position you will get
salary raises so the
more you think like a data scientist and
how to bring business value and
improve
efficiency and experience within
organizations and to your clients
the more value and recognition you get
internally and i think predictive
analytic skills are definitely more
advanced concepts and take a lot of time
and effort to learn
but i expect yeah you get the id there's
a lot of value to be gained if you
dedicate time and effort to learning
these these data science skills and if
if you take the time to learn to think
like a data scientist you will enhance
your career
for the rest of your life
every minute every hour you spend in
this will help you in your career so i
think this is i'm sorry stewart it's a
nice summary of how thinking like a data
scientist
can really help you
not only for your short term
but even for the long term basically for
for the rest of your life
thanks um
yeah that's a that's a
a great overview the
um there's
like questions from the audience that
have asked
related to this one which is
you know where do i start what what
things should i study what are the
different streams of data science and
you know starting from you know if i'm
not a data scientist where what's my
first step and if i am a
data scientist what are some of the
advanced things i should be looking at
so
yeah i can dive into the questions or
first or how do you would like to to
move on
actually i think if we start diving into
the questions they're going to answer
this one as well so let's let's do that
um
one of the questions
uh
if you're a beginner
uh shiva
shiva gabi asks
where what skill set should we be on
yeah if you look to
skill sets let's look at the skill sets
from a date scientist we discussed
already for example the communication
part and the collaboration part if we
look more to the the skill sets like um
analytic
logical thinking analytical thinking
critical thinking
if we look more to different signs like
mathematics
you can let's say dive a little bit more
deep into
skills
more practical skills um ai skills deep
learning skills
these are for the let's say the more
advanced people and if you look more
from the technical type of skills if you
want to go into that direction and
become a data scientist
yeah you you need technical skills like
python r um
sql
which are the most i think the most
popular skills that that you need
these la yeah this on one hand it's
let's say skills
if you really want to to become a data
scientist and the other thing is more
the way of of thinking
and
i really value people that start as some
kind of internship and you can think hey
but i am an experienced person already
10 years of experience in a certain
industry
why should i start an internship and
maybe the term internship is then not
always 100 right you can do it next to
your job but start
working
in a role how to use data
and
take as a junior analyst or junior data
scientist um next to that
follow a course
which can be online i mean if you can't
do the self-paced study
and you you don't have the motivation
for this and get some help um help for
online boot camps where you are drilled
in in eight to twelve weeks from from a
to z
and and you get the support and you get
the motivation by the people around you
so that's how you
can start
and how you can develop the skills and
what we we mentioned already initially
you need to define your own path it's
hard for me to say okay this is the path
that everybody should follow um but look
in the path okay what are your interests
where do you want to go
what are what are the industry that
you're in what is the typical role that
that you have and
what are the skills that i need within
that role maybe more specific skills
um
than what you have now that's i think
yeah a direction how to move this
forward
great
that relates to a couple of questions we
have several different people including
a couple on the youtube channel who have
asked about
moving into data science from other
fields like electronics engineering or
mechanical engineering
um
but
i think one foundational question is
what are the prerequisites for getting
into data science do you have to have
something that you need to know or be
good at before you can start learning
these skills
yeah so there's all the different kind
of levels i think if on one end if we
look to the statistics um
where quite some people have a master
degree 27
uh 10 have a doctorate uh 13
have have a bachelor degree and
46 had a phd
to my honest opinion
i think everybody who's interested can
start and it's more the way you think
and the background whether you have
studied
history which is totally not related but
you know how to think you know how to
study and you have an interest in in
data
you have a foundation for it and you can
start with it
it's maybe not that everybody agrees
with this statement but i believe if you
have the motivation and you have um
you're smart you can learn it and
that's i think that the key basis and
then
yes a bachelor degree
will be more or less a foundation
but even without a bachelor degree i
i see people that that are doing quite
quite well but it's more the way you
think and it's less
the type of education that you've done
it's more are you interested in it
do you have the drive
and yeah then you need the right support
from from the right people and the right
teams in your education what's what
steps to take and that can be within
your organization
start
doing more analytics work and what
junior data scientists are doing what
maybe internships
junior analysts are are doing
which sounds strange but that's how you
can start and can relate it to all the
business problems that you have and see
what
kind of challenges you have by
collecting the data
what kind of gaps you have
what kind of challenges you have by the
model creation
what kind of channels you have by the
visualization what kind of challenges
you have by automating your your
decisions you see the practicalities
from from data
and on the other hand you see the
opportunities from from from data
and by doing this
combining with professional support from
from companies like simply learn i think
that's a nice combination if you're
working already and if you
yeah you want to shift your career more
into the direction of
thinking like a data scientist
shivam had talked about
using data science and business analysis
and
it's so
fundamentally important because the
the
job of a business analyst is basically
to take
the data from the
operations of a company and turn it into
insights for for
management so
that's a direct example of
how data science uh thinking helps your
career
a couple of interesting questions a
couple questions about machine learning
and
if that's an area you should venture
into in fact our event is a little
worried that machine learning and ai are
going to
take over the job roles of data
scientists in the future by
completely automating them
but
what are your thoughts on
machine learning and ai
so you first need to have your
foundation and understanding data is
foundation the next step is
understanding analytics providing the
data visualizations
using predictive analytics start
creating models machine learning models
more supervised learning unsupervised
learning more
going into the direction of ai and deep
learning
and yes
a lot of tasks will be
augmented on one hand
or replaced
supported by ai
but i think we are humans we are great
in adapting ourselves
so we always need need to to watch and
look a couple of years ahead from what
are the capabilities and
yes
ai will take over a certain part of the
development
and that's something that that we we're
not yeah we can't avoid but i think as a
human you need to think okay what can be
then my role
if this part is automated and if we look
maybe 100 years back people were afraid
when there became machines
and machines taking over the all the
manual work
that's basically what what ai and
machine learning is doing now with
different apps but it also gives new
opportunities
for example the
the the example that i gave earlier
today where
voice
voice analysis
can detect what kind of disease you have
with a high certainty in this case 85
percent where you have covit
this gives new opportunities so if you
are the person who can think
like a data scientist and either come up
with ids to develop such an application
and look for the technical people around
you to create it
then you can think hey um
is ai taking over the people who are
testing for covit now during the
pandemic
or you can think about if we can do it
with an app
versus yes some pcr tests cost sixty
dollars some cost four hundred dollars
if you're at the airport
can it be for ten 10
or even less
doing a test now with 85 percent
accuracy
this way of thinking means
think in what's new what's possible what
innovation you can drive versus what
will it replace
will the people that do the test
be redundant by the solution yeah maybe
but on the other hand
there's new people
that we let's say that we can detect the
diseases and
where we can maybe um
educate them in healthcare
to recover the persons that are ill so
it's it's always thinking about okay
what can be automated and what can we do
and what will be my role and function
within
in society and how can i help but that's
why
what we addressed a couple of times
already is so important don't stop
your education it's a never-ending
process you need to be keen
watching
joining this type of webcast from
knowing what is there knowing what will
be automated what will be automated in
half a year what will be automated in
two years in five years with the immense
um
let's say
rays of compute power
many things can be automated and look to
this from from that perspective and then
think okay so what do i need to learn
today
to be
in an excellent position in a year and
in two years
and don't look too far ahead because
it's very hard to predict what what's
coming
and on the other hand if
parts of jobs will be automated it's not
from one day to the other it's not like
oh
somebody invented something new they
have a lot of challenges getting it to
the market rolling it out scaling it
and you can detect it you can easily
detect what's coming and then you need
to know oh i need to rescale
myself again because this part will be
automated so
20 of my job will maybe ought to be
automated
what 20 of new things do i need to learn
to deliver value so it's a different way
of thinking not seeing it as a threat
because there's more jobs created by ai
half a million
then than that that are lost
so i see everything what we do with new
technology as an opportunity to create
new jobs versus the risk that it
replaces a job and if it replaces my job
i'm
let's say a speaker we have now
synthetic avatars who can speak as well
so i need to think about how can i work
with synthetic avatars
that do speaking similar like like me um
maybe it's maybe i'm redundant as a
speaker in in a year's time but i need
to think about new ways how to
to use my knowledge and to educate the
market and maybe i'm going to use
synthetic avatars to explain my story so
i can do 10 broadcast at the same time
that's how you need to think
exactly
um
we have some questions that will hold
for a future session um uh i think a
great future topic would be
advanced topics in
data science we have people asking about
data engineering
um analytics streams about
privacy and other considerations like
that but we're running uh
shorter time today so
if we
haven't gotten to your question i
apologize but
you do need to move on i am going to
take over the the screen sharing at this
point and
i want to just show you one image before
we move on
and
let me do that
thank you everybody i'm going to my next
session
okay thank you so much ronald for being
here with us um
and
i will
finish out the uh
last part of the webinar for everyone
this is the picture i wanted to share
with you i think you're looking at
the internal uh the cab the operator cab
for a modern combine harvester
when you talk about
the impact of
things like machine learning ai
data
and automation
in
the united states
we went from 70 people per uh 70 of the
people
involved in agriculture in the 19th
century
to 3 percent and it's because
of this type of technology first
mechanical and now the data
technology that increases crop yields
and makes it possible for
an individual to
farm much more land at much higher yield
than any one person could have done in
the past so
this is where data is
affecting everyone everywhere in every
kind of job
i just wanted to
share that one with you but
what we'll
do now is
ask
our final poll question for today
and again we're hoping that the
technology cooperates
and here's a poll i'll put it up on the
on the screen as well
this poll is what topics are you
interested in learning so
if you're watching on a streaming
service you can put
answers from the right hand column into
your
[Music]
comments
we're asking people
what
topics and what time frame they're
you're looking at
and we've got about 10 more seconds on
the poll
and
i'll share the poll results
so unsurprisingly uh three quarters of
the audience is interested in
data science skills
ai and ml are also popular
and project management
understanding how to apply things within
your organization so that's important
and
you see that about
uh
40 of the audience more than a third are
interested in doing
uh adding to their skill sets right away
so
that's also good to see
i'm just going to briefly mention
first off a thank you to ronald who has
moved to his next session but i wanted
to thank
emma uh
and let you know how to get in touch
with him so i'm going to drop this
linkedin
link into the chat
so that you're able to
click that directly and go to his
linkedin page
and
i'm going to mention
one of our programs
we have a whole series of programs
from individual courses on particular
topics
like how to use
individualization tools
on up to a program like this one which
is affiliated with purdue university
which end with ibm and
provides you with a full
curriculum to learn how to become a data
scientist so
we have
i'll drop the link into the chat here
and once you go to that page you'll be
able to explore other uh
options in our data science categories
and other categories as well so
we invite you to join us next
tuesday for a career webinar
on interviewing
and this is with
a leading career counselor
minati
czecho navis
who is also a faculty member sorry um um
at
platinum women's college
and also a television interviewer so
she's got a lot of experience has met a
lot of people and can share a lot of
useful insights
on
how to crack your next interview and
i've just dropped that link into the
chat as well
so we invite you to
join us next tuesday for that
and with that
that concludes our webinar
so
we invite you to join us
on our social media channels at simply
learn
that's uh facebook on twitter and simply
learn on linkedin
and we hope to see you at future
webinars and to welcome you into the
simply learn learning community
thank you all for being here today
and
have a
great rest of your evening
day
or wherever you are
you